Sam's in New York hi Sam welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave it's a pleasure
to be on how are you honor to have you
how can I help
well I'm a 17 year old high school and I
was working my butt off recently on the
weekends just to buy a car but money was
real tire on the family so most of it
has to go off the to help my parents so
whatever money I had I put down on a
down payment on a $15,000 car at about
5k down so I'm financing 10k for about
four five years I'm going to try to pay
it off within this year I'm able to do
it
I make OK money in the weekend my
question is I'm going to spend about 500
to get new speakers for the car or
should I wait until it's fully paid off
hopefully within the less than a year
and AD Sam you're not gonna like me at
all I don't even think you ought to have
this car you 17 years old you're $10,000
in debt on a $15,000 car that just makes
my stomach hurt for you and you've
started a pattern here at 17 years old
that if you're not careful it's gonna
take you to 37 they're going to break
this pattern because not only did you do
that you figured out in your mind how
that was smart and it wasn't smart but
now you're saying I don't even want to
pay it off early instead I'm open
speakers in it and you know what happens
after the speakers are done well then we
got to put some mills in it oh and then
the brakes go out oh then we got about
tires and you should bought a car you
could buy cash for that's what I would
have told you how to caught you ahead of
time and I might even reverse this
decision by selling this car and buy a
cheap car that could pay cash for I
don't like this car I don't like this
car owning you at 17 years old sir I
understand what you're saying but the
thing is that my mom wouldn't let me get
another car because this is a bit newer
it's used it's all-wheel drive this is
your mother who's so broke that she had
to have you help support her
this is the same woman yeah it is yeah
bad decisions dude all over your own
family bad decisions you know and so
your mother is wrong and obviously she
doesn't know how to handle money because
her seventeen year old son is helping to
support her so you guys are going to sit
down and rethink how you make money
decisions around your place because
every one of them so far has been wrong
I cannot imagine being in the financial
condition that my seventeen year old had
to give me money that would destroy me
and on top of that I turn around tell
him he needs to go deeply in debt and
buy a car he can't afford I'm serious
dude bad situation here so hold on I'm
gonna send your family a book called the
total money makeover because this family
needs one and I'll help you if you read
the book but if you want speakers and
you want to keep a car you can't afford
and you want to keep handling money the
way your mom does who has no money then
I can't help you but if you want to win
with money you can start making some
different decisions and you'll start
winning with money but hold on we'll try
to give you a hand up I'll send you a
book and we'll see how it works from
there if you want to talk about it
further I'll be happy to talk about it
and if your mother doesn't like me
saying she's broke and shouldn't be
giving financial advice she can call me
I'll talk to her be happy to talk to her
hey thanks for the call hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]